hey everyone welcome back to our Channel
today we are diving into the world of
cyber security focusing on a crucial
element that helps Safeguard our digital
landscape s or security information and
event management and just a quick info
for you if you want to upskill yourself
or Master cyber security skills and
learn your dream job or grow in your
career then you must explore simply
learn scope of various cyber Security
Programs simply learn offers various
certification and postgraduate programs
in collaboration with some of the
world's leading universities like MIT I
kpur EC Council and many more through
our courses you will gain knowledge and
work ready expertise in skills like
Advanced hacking Concepts Network packet
analysis ethical hacking network
security and over a dozen others and
that's not all you also get the
opportunity to work on multiple projects
and learn from industry experts work
working in Top Tire product and security
companies and medians repeat and
academicians from top universities after
completing these courses thousands of
Learners have transitioned into a cyber
security role as a fresher or move on to
a higher paying job and profile if you
are passionate about making your career
in this field then make sure to check
out the link in the pin comment and
description box to find a cyber security
program that fits your experience and
areas of Interest so let's get started
so so cyber security is more important
than ever in our interconnected world
and at the heart of it s a powerful tool
that plays a pivotal role in securing
our digital assets and now we'll start
with what is s security information and
event management s is a holistic
security approach merging security
information management that is s and
security event management sem and
pronounced s with a silent e s
Aggregates data detects anomalies and
triggers actions initially for large
Enterprises it now safeguards smaller
organizations from persistent threats
and now we'll understand the concept in
simple terms imagine you have a magical
detective robot on your computer and its
job is to keep your favorite games and
pictures safe this robot is called s
which stands for super important
electronic monitor s is like a superhero
because it watches everything happening
in your Computer World if there's
anything strange or not normal s notices
and says oh something is not right just
like how superheroes protect it is s
protects your computer World from bad
guys who might want to sneak in and do
naughty things so whenever your computer
needs a superhero Sim is there to save
the day and make sure everything stays
happy and safe in your Digital
Playground and now we'll see rule based
or using statistical correlation engines
s evolves with user and entity Behavior
analytics and security orchestration
Automation and response mechanically Sim
employs agents to collect events from
devices servers networks and security
tools sending data to a centralized
console analyst then analyze prioritize
and respond reducing cyber security
noise effectively and now we'll see how
does the functionality of s unfold
S tools aggregate event and log data
from various systems in an organization
this data is centralized and includes
information from applications security
devices antivirus filters and Fireballs
s meticulously categorizes this data
identifying successful or unsucessful
Logans malare activity and potential
malicious behavior when potential
security issues are detected s generates
security alerts based on predefined
rules allowing organ ganizations to
prioritize them for example 25 failed
login attempts in 25 minutes might be
flagged as suspicious with a lower
priority while one 30 failed attempts in
5 minutes would be a high priority event
indicating a possible Brute Force attack
requiring immediate attention and now
moving to why is Sim important so Sim
streamlined Security Management sifting
through vast data to prioritize alerts
for Enterprises it incurs potential
incidents identifying malicious activity
in log entries and reconstructing attack
sequences meeting compliance is
simplified with automated comprehensive
reports eliminating manual efforts and
crucially S AIDS Incident Management by
tracking attack Parts pinpointing
compromis sources and offering automated
tools to thrat ongoing threats stay
secure stay compliant That's The Power
of sim in a nutshell and now we'll see
the advantages of sim
discover the numerous advantages that
security information and event
management s brings to the Ser security
table number one is rapid threat
identification Sim significantly reduces
the time needed to identify potential
threats minimizing the potential damage
inited by malicious activities next is
holistic security view Sim offers a
comprehensive perspective of an
organization's information security
environment this facilitates the effic
ient Gathering and Analysis of security
information ensuring the overall safety
of systems all organizational data is
centralized enhancing accessibility next
is versatile use cases companies
leverage SIM for a range of applications
centered around data and logs this
includes implementing robust cyber
Security Programs generating audit and
compliance reports and adding in help
desk and network troubleshooting and
then comes scalability s supports large
volume of data enabling organizations to
seamlessly scale and incorporate
additional data as needed for enhanced
security measures and then comes threat
detection and alerts s provides
proactive threat detection and issues
security alerts allowing organizations
to stay ahead of potential risk and then
comes forensic analysis capability in
the unfortunate event of significant
security breaches s proves invaluable by
conducting detailed forensic analysis
this AIDS in understanding the scope and
impact of secured incidents facilitating
effective response strategies embrace
the power for Sim repeat embrace the
power of s for a fortified cyber
security posture where Swift threat
identification and proactive measures
are the keys to a secure digital
landscape and now coming to the S
limitations so starting with limitations
number one is implementation Time s
integration while beneficial demands
time successful implementation involves
thoro support to seamlessly integrate
with an organization security controls
and host typically it takes 90 plus days
for full operational setup and the next
limitation is cost factors s's upfront
cost is substantial of an exceeding
hundreds of thousands of dollars ongoing
expenses including personal support fees
and data collection tools contribute to
a significant financial commitment and
then comes expertise requirement if Ive
s Management demands High expertise some
opt for a dedicated security operations
center staffed with a skilled
information security team to handle the
system and then comes rule based
analysis s relies on rules for data
analysis however the vast data volume
poses challenges with thousands of
alerts daily making it harder to
identify potential threats and then
comes misconfiguration risk
misconfigured Sim is a significant risk
potentially overlook looking crucial
security events accurate setup is vital
for maximizing threat detection and
response so these were the limitations
and now we'll explore s features or S
features and capabilities so when diving
into security information and event
management it's crucial to understand
the key features that contribute to its
Effectiveness let's break down the
essential aspects to consider Ben
evaluating Sim products number one data
integration Sim operates by collecting
and monitoring data from diverse sources
including applications networks servers
and databases the next is correlation a
Wier component often integrated into
security event management within a Sim
tool correlation involves identifying
common attributes among different events
this AIDS in comprehensive threat
analysis and then comes dashboards Sim
systems excellent data aggregation
pulling information from applications
databases networks and servers this data
is then presented in visually accessible
dashboards featuring charts that unveil
patterns and prevent the oversight of
critical events and then comes alerting
when a potential security incident is
identified Sim tools are equipped to
promptly notify users this realtime
alerting is instrumental in enabling
Swift responses to emerging threats and
then comes and then comes the next
feature that is automation some Sim
Solutions go beyond basic
functionalities incorporating automation
features
this may include automated security
incident analysis incident response
mechanisms these automated processes
enhance the efficiency of the overall
cyber security strategy in essence and
organizations assess s options these
features become integral bench marks for
selecting a solution that not only meets
their current cyber security needs but
also positions them strategically to
adapt to evolving threads in the digital
landscape and now coming to S tools and
software in the realm of cyber security
a diverse set of tools empowers
organizations to fortify their digital
defenses here's a glimpse into some not
worthy options number one is Splunk then
comes IBM Q radar then logarithm then
comes solar winds and then manage engine
log 360 and then comes data dog Cloud
Sim and then comes the exam beam and
then net Fitness automating threat
detection security policy monitoring and
network protection solar wind security
EV manager is equipped with features
like Integrity monitoring compliance
reporting and centralized LW collection
the cyber security landscape is evolving
and these Sim tools play a pivotal role
in ensuring proactive security measures
for organizations of all sizes and now
coming to Sim's future landscape and
what to expect so we can expect Advanced
orchestration that that is s's role in
workflow automation is evolving with AI
and machine learning expect faster
orchestration ensuring all company
departments receive height and
protection this means more efficient and
effective security protocol execution
and then comes collaboration with MDR
tools as hacking threats rise a dual
tired approach is crucial internal it
teams can utilize IIM while many service
providers Implement MDR tools ensuring a
comprehensive response to security
and then comes elevated Cloud management
s vendors are enhancing tools for better
Cloud management aligning the evolving
security needs of organizations immersed
in Cloud environments and then comes
integration of S and S the line between
Sim and S is blurring traditional Sim
products adopt sore benefits and S
vendors are expand functionalities
fering a convergence leveraging both
approaches so stay tuned for these
exciting Transformations shaping the
future of sim and cyber security and
this was all for this tutorial thanks
for joining us today and next time stay
secure stay informed and see you in the
next video staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive C blog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here